Not For the First Time refugees and
migrants dying at sea but more lives
were saved and lost as fishermen pulled
people to safety from the icy waters of
the English Channel a rigid inflatable
boat with people on board
migrants was crossing and was sinking
very very near to where he was fishing
so
um amazingly he got right in next to the
the sinking boat and managed to
come alongside and and safely get 31
people on board this latest tragedy is
once again down to people traffickers
they're not deterred by freezing weather
neither it seems other migrants
Channel Crossings is an ongoing
humanitarian crisis and people
traffickers have never been busier at
the same time politicians are running
short of ideas on how to stop them
it is not cruel or unkind to want to
break the Stranglehold of the criminal
gangs who trade in human misery and who
exploit our system and our laws
I'm sure the whole house will share my
sorrow at the capsizing of a small boat
in the channel in the early hours of
this morning and the tragic loss of
human life our hearts go out to all
those affected less than 24 hours before
these deaths UK prime minister Rishi
sunak had been talking about new
measures to curb the channel Crossings
but so far every measure the UK
government introduces has failed there
needs to be safe in legal Roots that's
the biggest issue that we've got at the
moment is that people are making the
journey from Calais because there is no
other way of doing it you have to be on
British soil on the island in order to
seek Asylum there's no Center in Calais
where you can claim Asylum so people
have no choice but to make this journey
and that is the single biggest thing
that the government could do in order to
prevent people having to risk their
lives
here at Dover Lifeboat station they've
seen it all before people trafficking
across the channel is at record levels
40 000 this year and at the weekend
alone 500 risked their lives tragedies
are all too frequent this time more
lives were saved than lost but that
isn't always the case
last November 27 lives were lost in the
channel the highest number ever recorded
a diplomatic spat followed between
France and the UK with the British
saying the French should do more to stop
the small boats from leaving their
Shoreline
as the Lifeboat Crews will tell you the
crossings are ever more frequent and
dangerous Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera
Dover